bella tutti ragazzi e beve questo video
sono fatti beh fa niente mi sono
permesso di giocare a geometri perché
era da un pochettino che non ci giocavo
cos'è sta roba
questa la versione di geometri insieme a
tempo run niente praticamente mi mette
ansia per cortesia non facciamo più
livelli del genere 11 l'ho già finito
poi non si sa mai
i prossimi va bene già così posso
concludere il video la che teoricamente
quello che devo fare hanno fatto ci sono
stati video non hanno affatto mango 1 è
quindi siamo già meglio del solito
ragazzi ho provato a fare una roba che
faccio anche su bwin che è praticamente
iniziare a fare i livelli più recenti
che sono usciti quindi questi sono
praticamente nuovi e ammazzati compiute
a 2.080 ci manca solo che non mi va dai
geometri dash al cavallo che sfiga tosto
livello la ragazza con figo porca vacca
è difficilissimo dato non si capisce una
sega cioè per me che sono il gruppo è
difficilissimo ha forse devo stare fermo
e basta di merito che stai per me basta
pronto a tutto pronto ho letto è
ovviamente non è in italiano
a me a livello automatico ma io che mi
stavo io che ero tutto figo che mi di
giuro mi stavo preparando tantissimo
ma cavolo volevo giocarli livelli porto
le mani ero veramente comunità di
doverlo fare io
kalac veramente picco bravo mi piace che
è difficile cioè senso la mia vita è
piena di ostacoli ma non oggi oggi oggi
no sono riuscito a perdere anche in un
livello automatico pensate che sfigato
nella vita proprio dai ragazzi non
facciamo livelli automatici facciamo
europa dove posso far vedere che perdo
ma porca vacca motiva mente vi state
veramente impegnando ma che dico che
livelli pazzeschi outer space speriamo
che non mi copyright in orbita sono vi
ammazzo parco lemonia
[Musica]
bella bella ragazzi non so quanto sia
duraturo e vabbè ma non mi metti
l'ostacolo che ne so ma porca vacca non
c'era l'ostacolo non vale mamma mia che
belli vello ultimamente ho bellissimi ho
il piacere giocare di geometri quando è
così o comunque non fate troppo
affidamento su di me perché non è che
sono infatti è che so proprio esperto
anche perché non vedo gli ostacoli non
so se gli esperti di geometria e vendono
gli ostacoli dove io non li vedo proprio
allora perché a volte non vedo proprio
come tua madre ad esempio ok questo è
buono non mi ricordo dove sono morto
prima ecco qua la donna raga non vedo
gli ostacoli per loro aiuto
va bene così meglio così almeno c'era
più porco il demonio porco morto l'altro
ieri
ok ok buono
piano sono morto prima qua perfetto a
posto non vedo di un robottino
ti ho sbagliato non me fate gaga addosso
per prego il robottino io non lo so
usare cioè non lo uso l'uso talmente
poco che quando mi compare ammazzerei
piuttosto e tipo una roba che ti tieni
premuto che salino non è ferma donna se
volevo come ammazzato non vedo porco il
demonio e chi l'ha creato ma dimmi te
dal demonio ha creato di dio quindi
magari non saranno ammesse no scherzavo
cioè allora questo robot porca vacca se
non mi devono far girare le balle non lo
so io
poter poter non inventare costoro
portiere vita mi chiamo non sei una
vendita dove sono morto prima non mi
ricordo che ero molto noti dopo ero
molto quali l'attenzione e lo fa
attenzione
no marca
sono un deficit allora il sé per sé non
è un livello difficile il problema
sapete quale è che tutti insieme si è
difficile che poi comunque il 99 per
cento dei problemi dei livelli di
geometria alla fine non sono troppo
difficili ma fatti tutti insieme non ti
puoi ricordare tutto ford ka barca
[Musica]
cosmai ice na sega proprio penso che
geometri dash sia l'unico gioco in grado
di farmi dare è di farmi odiare questo
tipo di musica che a me piace il
problema è che porca vacca mi fa sentire
satana di certi momenti si può questo
siamo
molto buono
molto buono ha più dio ok allora calmi
schiatto sempre quindi calmi
ho sbagliato ovunque
e non vedo
[Musica]
non parte mai sto troppo bene
porca vacca parti direi ragazzi l'ultima
scherzavo ai ragazzi fare l'ultimo ha
fatto molto bene ma forse questo è un po
corto porca vacca ho beccato trash
fantastico bello una sfida difficile
nella mia vita non potevo sperare di
meglio vediamo su una roma un po più
fattibile da allora come matrix perfetto
ma non c entrano neanche come pretendi a
fossero passati sotto banco parte la
meuse in questo aiuto come ultimo
livello scelto proprio quello sbagliato
solo nome bene spero di non morire
perché la parte che non so fare e
l'inizio proprio esatto è però quello
che era successo aiuto
una volta passato l'inizio finito il
livello è l'inizio che edificio ok
bene bene per favore de facto date non
di copyright aree blu ray tisi canzone
bellissima
io amo questo artista l'unica roba che
non c'è in questo livello e la
difficoltà porca vacca e copyright
gratis
mettili degli ostacoli to sorella toce
pensavo ci fosse scritto oggi schiva
niente nemmeno però grazie gentile
allora va l'edizione
o forse è questo è fatto ovviamente
livello abbastanza normale ma dove devi
giocare tu porca che anche gli altri
marzo mi stavo randellando dei maroni
che devo fà qua stavo riuscendo amorin
cork col demonio forte sporca perché
pensavo fosse tutta una presa per il
deretano pure questo che alla fine c'è
tutta na roma dritta invece c'è
sarebbero destabilizzanti st
questo corridoio 1 2 3 dei marca baccalà
80 per cento imortacci mia mente
diventato difficile cioè questo livello
abbastanza easy e che è lunga sta roba
cosa sta parlando ora e mezza qui porca
vacca dai panni dello serio madonna mi
danno più imitate picenardi voi che fate
sti livelli dove stai fermo 1 o round
ove non devi toccare niente che le morti
in sé 12345678
molto buono e non ci arrivo e fallo che
ci arriva ma setino per passettino lo
finiremo ragazzi intanto era da prendere
e alla pesca da te prego a siamo siamo
ci siamo
buono proprio lui ha messo un po ma l'ho
fatto ma l'importante per questo i nomi
al demonio li fate a casa vostra non a
casa mia grazie va bene fa basta però ho
giocato c'è c'erano livelli calini oggi
livelli belli fate un po di livelli
giocabili un po di più però però belli
non ho fatto troppe figure di kakà anche
perché non ho scelto quelli difficili
che hanno fatto incazzare lo stesso però
alla pianista dalla pesca iscriviti al
canale schiacciate il tasto mi piace e
noi ci vediamo hanno proseguito come
sempre ragazzino che lasci può che
portare solo roba fatta bene c'è proprio
tipo il livello quello del robottino che
vedere se riesco a trovare una dignità
nel finiresti livelli troppo non è
sempre detto ma è finiamo su video dai
siamo arrivati a 10 minuti ben bella
[Musica]
no